[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to the
Data Science Hangout.
I hope everybody's
having a great week.
If we haven't met before,
I'm Rachael Dempsey.
I lead our pro
community at Posit.
Before I forget to
say this, I want
to share an exciting
announcement
that the call for talks at
Posit conference in Chicago
in September was
extended to April 7.
So you have a little bit
more time to procrastinate.
[LAUGHS] So if anybody
wants to submit a talk,
I'll put the updated blog
post into the chat here too.
But thanks again for
joining us today.
The Data Science Hangout
is our open space
to chat about data science
leadership, questions
you're facing, and getting
to hear about what's
going on in the world of data
across different industries.
And so if you are watching
this on YouTube in the future,
in our future world, it
happens every Thursday
at the same time, same place.
So you can add it to your
calendar with the details.
That would be below
in the YouTube.
But every week, we feature a
different data science leader
as my co-host to help lead
our discussion and answer
questions from you all.
Together at the
Hangout, we're all
dedicated to making this
a welcoming environment
for everybody.
We love when everybody
can participate,
no matter your level of
experience or industry
or area of work.
It is totally OK to
just listen in too.
There's always three
ways, though, that you
could jump in and ask
questions or provide
your own perspective.
So you can jump in by raising
your hand here on Zoom,
and I'll look out for it.
You can put questions
in the Zoom chat,
and feel free to put a
little star next to it
if you wanted me or
read it if you're
in a coffee shop or something.
Otherwise, I'll just call on
you to jump in and introduce
yourself.
And then, third, we
also have a Slido link,
where you can ask
questions anonymously.
And I believe Hannah and Tyler
will be sharing that-- yep--
in the chat just a second.
Thank you so much again for
joining us, and thank you, Dan.
Dan Negrey is Director of
Analytics at MarketBridge
and is joining as
our co-host today.
Dan, I'd love to have you jump
in and introduce yourself,
then maybe share a little
bit about your role,
and also something you
like to do outside of work.
Sure.
Thanks, Rachael, and thanks
for having me here today.
I was super excited about
it when you reached out.
I was thrilled.
I love talking about this stuff.
So as Rachael
mentioned, I'm Director
of Analytics at MarketBridge.
We're a-- call ourselves
go-to-market science company,
and so we really use
reproducible scientific methods
to tackle our clients'
toughest measurement problems
in sales and marketing.
My role is--
I wear a lot of hats, but
I guess, primarily, I'm
focused on our tooling
and our approach
to building tools
that we can apply
across different
problems, as well as some
of the front-end
stuff we do with Shiny
and serving up
insights to clients
based on the models we build.
I'm sure we'll get into more
questions about some of that,
but I'm from Cleveland, Ohio.
I live right outside of
Cleveland, and outside of work,
I love playing basketball.
Awesome.
Thank you, Dan.
So to kind of put us in
your mindset of the problems
that you're helping
to solve, what's
an example of a marketing
use case or maybe a problem
you've helped the
stakeholder with?
Sure.
Probably the most common
problem that we work on
that every company
is challenged with
is measuring their
marketing effectiveness.
Or you think about all
the different efforts
you do from a marketing
perspective-- reaching out
to customers directly
through different channels,
direct mail, email, phone,
spending money on paid ads,
on various social media
channels, and paid search,
and all that kind of stuff.
So we help our clients measure
those efforts effectively
and in a way that doesn't
double count or overattribute.
So we've got some
very smart approaches
to these sorts of problems
and some very creative ways
to address them.
So maybe these
could be related,
but I know on past
Hangouts, we've
talked a lot about community,
and so, for example,
like an internal
meetup and being
able to show the value of that
within your own organization.
Do you have some
tips for people here
who might be trying to do that?
Well, I would say,
without getting too
into the weeds in
some of this stuff,
try to think of the
problems in more broad ways.
It's like, what is your goal?
Like, is your goal to--
by having internal meetups,
is your goal to get-- like,
what's your objective?
What's your measurable
objective on the back end?
Are you trying to
get more people
to register for these
events going forward?
Or is it more of a
softer lead type of thing
to get people to sign
up for the conference,
and just using
Posit as an example.
But think about the
problem holistically
before you start diving
into polling data
and arranging data
and all that stuff
because the more you
can think about it--
the bigger picture of what's
going on, the more you'll
be able to--
want to explain what you're
doing to other people,
but also think about how all
the different pieces that
affect what you're trying to
measure can come into play
and work together
with each other.
Thank you.
So I get to ask you
all the questions
right in the beginning, as
we're thinking of the ones--
as people are
thinking of their own.
But I know you said
you use Shiny a bit,
so I'd love to hear
a little bit more
about how you're
using Shiny today.
Sure.
So, first of all,
I'm a huge fan,
and I've been
following the product.
It's called Product Along
since it first launched,
and I knew it was
going to be a game
changer because, at the
time, you could already
do some really incredible
stuff visually with R.
And the moment I saw how the
reactive framework worked
and how to manipulate
things and have
it change what users
were looking at,
I knew it was going
to be awesome.
So I've spent a lot of time in
the last seven or eight years--
can't remember how
long it's been--
trying to get better
and trying to learn
the ins and outs of Shiny.
But at the end of the
day, I look at it like--
your ability to create in a tool
like ours is pretty limitless.
Like, there are so many--
like, I compare it
to LEGOs, right?
There's all sorts of
cool LEGO sets out there.
Think of a package
maybe as a LEGO set.
And the fact that you can just
pull from different packages,
and you can kind of create
your own original LEGO
creation from all
these different,
really strong and stable
parts that come underneath it.
So as soon as you kind of
accept that, and then you think
how Shiny can take
that to the next level,
you're kind of giving your users
the ability to take your LEGOs
and rearrange them
in different ways
and do some cool stuff with it.
So now to talk a little bit more
about actual work-related stuff
and not LEGOs, but with our--
I like the LEGOs explanation.
That's helpful.
Yeah, but with what we do--
think about building marketing
measurement or
marketing mix models.
When we can serve
those up to our clients
and have them change
the data around
that they are scoring
those models on-- maybe
they're making
assumptions around
how they might spend
differently next quarter
on a certain channel.
Or maybe their budget's
going to be reduced,
and they need to
scale things back.
They can rescore the
models, and all that's
happening on the
reactive back end.
They're using some inputs
to change assumptions
around the data and then
having the models get rescored.
And, oh, someone pointed
something about Duplos, yeah.
[LAUGHS]
But, yeah, that's a lot of it--
seeing visuals get
regenerated that show time
series plots or tables that
have some way to summarize data.
That's a lot of what
we're doing, manipulating
those models on the back end
and restoring them and showing
results in different ways.
Awesome.
Alan, I see you just asked
a question in the chat.
Do you want to jump in here?
Yeah, sure.
Hi, Dan.
I've been learning a
little bit about some
of what our teams are doing
with marketing effectiveness
measurement lately, and
it's an interesting space,
and there's a ton of
challenges and stuff to learn.
So this is timely and fun to get
to learn from you a little bit.
I'm curious if you can talk
a little bit about your team
and what the roles are there.
And maybe say a little bit
more about, as a director,
are you leading people,
or is your leadership
in a more of a kind of
technical space or a mix,
and how you find that balance?
Sure, great question.
So my role is in a little bit
more of a technical space.
We do have a good structure
to our team, though, I think.
It's a little tough to
describe because it's
a mixture of sort of flat
but also with specialty.
So we know we have-- and
this is an important thing
I was hoping to bring up at
some point in this conversation.
But where I've seen
teams fail or not
succeed as well is when
people are trying to--
there's a single role that
leadership has in mind,
and everyone has to
fit into that role.
And that's not the
case that we have here.
We have people that are
really good with theoretical
statistics, and we
have people that
are really good with data
storage and data storage
solutions and data
engineering, I guess.
We have people that
are good with Shiny,
and we have people good
with data visualization.
So what we try to do is we-- it
involves a lot of communication
too and breaking projects down
into individual components,
where we can say who fits
best on those components
so that we can get the best out
of everybody while also giving
exposure to different
components so that people
can learn in different areas.
But recognizing
those differences
and trying to get the most
out of people's expertise
is huge for that.
I see there was an
anonymous question.
It goes back to us
talking about Shiny,
and it said, "Do you think that
the main value that R provides
is Shiny?"
And this person
said, "Personally, I
find the overemphasis
on Shiny sometimes
makes R seem like a
limited language."
And I was curious to get
your thoughts on that.
Yeah, that's a good question.
It's a good point.
I don't see it that
way because I've
been using R for a long time
and have seen it evolve.
So, obviously, I think--
it wasn't by much,
but I believe R Markdown
preceded the release of Shiny.
So that was pretty
innovative at the time.
You could create reports in
all sorts of different formats
and embed output and code.
And so that is still
a great use case.
In fact, that's
one of the things
when I'm talking to clients.
And in best-case
scenario, we have
clients that can log
into our environment
and see some of the cool stuff
we create in our environment.
But there are other
cases when, just by--
I'm sure everybody on the phone
here has been in a situation
where they've had to work in a
different computing environment
without all the
resources that they would
love to have at their disposal.
So we find ourselves in
that situation sometimes,
and when we're fortunate
enough to have even the ability
to install RStudio
Desktop or something,
your ability to create
those types of reports
now becomes on the table.
And one thing that I
think gets overlooked
a lot is all the really
cool and somewhat
interactive visualizations you
can do in R Markdown output.
But I'm a huge fan of those HTML
widgets collection of packages,
so like DT for tables
and Leaflet for maps,
and dygraphs for time series
plots, and things like that.
A lot of clients and
companies you might work with
may have never even seen
something like that before.
They might not
even know that they
could get a static document that
has an embedded map with icons
for individual
lat/long coordinates,
and polygons for
shapes, and they
have hover over to see
different information
at different regions.
So those have gone
a long way, right?
I mean, they've gone a
long way with clients.
They've been received very
well, and that obviously
stopped short of
Shiny reactivity.
But then even just as an
exploratory or language
to explore data, manipulate
data, generate plots
in the Viewer, even pasting
those into PowerPoint,
even if they're static
plots, can go a long way,
and, of course, building
models and generating
insights around inferential
statistics as well.
Absolutely.
I think also we talk
about Shiny apps
a lot and the
visualizations because it's
fun to talk about the
things that are created
and things that people are
actually using and interacting
with.
A question-- I'm not sure if
I'm going to frame this question
the right way or if I fully
thought about it, but I--
so I read the book,
Checklist Manifesto,
and I've been thinking
about if there
may be some sort of
checklist for providing value
to an organization or a way
for your team to best impact
the business with data science.
And I was wondering
if there's something
that comes to mind for you,
like something that you say,
oh, you definitely need to
have this to provide impact
on the business.
Let me think about that
because there was a little bit
[INAUDIBLE].
Yeah, I'm still forming what
I want that question to be.
Like, a tip for all of us
on impacting the business
with data science.
Mhm, mhm.
So I think every business
is going to have KPIs,
and there's going to be
other metrics besides KPIs,
things that lead into that.
And as crazy as it sounds,
some organizations struggle
to measure those and to do so
in a consistent and repeatable
way, you know?
So maybe they measure
something that
just comes from one
person sitting at a desk,
and they've done it for
six years, and they leave,
and all of a sudden, who
knows how they do that?
So just getting in a--
creating a framework for
consistent measurement
is huge for an
organization, right?
The measurement is consistent.
The outcomes are
measured consistently.
Then taking action to
improve those outcomes
can be thought of
as more reliable
because the measurement
process is consistent.
So that would be
one thing for sure.
And I guess another--
on that note, it's
decisioning, right?
Every company makes
decisions in there.
A lot of us are here because we
like to do this kind of work,
but most of our companies
exist because they
like to make money,
and they like to grow.
And so we find a
balance between doing
what we do to help our company
to achieve their goals.
And so if you can find ways to
help your company optimize cost
and reduce waste and
increase growth--
and, again, all of that
is through measuring
and looking at decisions that
have been made in the past
and thinking about how
they could have been made
differently and doing
historical analysis or building
models to help make
those decisions
more effectively--
then that's obviously
a huge win for any organization.
Thank you.
Josh, I see you had asked
a question in the chat.
Do you to jump in?
And maybe introduce
yourself because you'll
be joining us as a featured
leader in a few weeks here too.
Sure.
Thanks, Rachael.
Yeah, so I'm Josh King.
I think, April 20, I'll be a
[AUDIO OUT] leader as well.
And similar to you,
Dan, I focus a lot
on marketing data science.
One of the things that really
caught my ear earlier--
you referencing you
have a Shiny framework,
and you reference specifically
MMM as an input to that
and being able to--
for your clients
to use that as a scoring
mechanism for new models.
So I'm curious to try to give
some thought to this myself
in the past.
Are you using that as a means
for actually constructing
MMM for your clients?
Or is it more of a
scenario-planning aspect
to utilize response curves
coming out of MMM for them
to actually use it
as a tool for them?
And the reason that I've had
a lot of struggle wrapping
my head around
this in the past is
I see MMM not necessarily as
a specific model, necessarily,
but more of a
framework to build out
what it is that you're
trying to measure, which
is very human in
the loop, which is
kind of different from a lot
of other data science projects.
It's very much a blend of
the art and the science
of having a balance
between statistical fit,
as well as business fit.
So I'm curious, within the the
apps you've built in the past,
like how you're able
to find that balance.
Yeah, great question,
and nice to meet you, Josh.
It's almost like you've spoken
to some of our leaders here,
and they planted that question
with you, but we are--
currently, I would say the
state is more of the latter
that you mentioned, taking
models that our team has worked
very hard to build
and very precise
and serving those up in a way
to give clients the ability
to understand how
those models work,
and consider different scenarios
where they think about how they
might manipulate
spend differently,
or what would happen if this
happens sort of a thing.
But totally agree on your
point about making it
more of a fluid
application, where
it's not just reacting to
something that's been built,
but also has a hand in
building it to begin with.
So that's definitely in mind
and on our roadmap for how
we approach these things.
It's just it's actually one
of the more exciting things
that I think about that I'm
working on this year, so
great question.
So we were double-checking
in the chat on what MMM stands
for and thought it might
be helpful to include with
the recording too.
So what is MMM?
[LAUGHS]
So you might hear different
answers from people,
but Marketing Mix Models
or Media Mix Models.
But, basically,
when you look at--
you consider all
the different types
of marketing
stimulus or marketing
efforts that go towards
a measurable objective.
And it's trying to consider all
those things at the same time
and assign contributions by
each effort towards the outcome,
and do so in a way that doesn't
double count or overattribute--
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Thank you.
DAN NEGREY: --or
anything like that.
Great.
Well, we had both of those
definitions there in the chat.
Sirdark-- and apologies if
I'm pronouncing your name
incorrectly--
I see you had a follow-up
question on MMM.
You want to jump in?
And a question-- let
me just scroll up.
The question was, "What are
the shortcomings of MMM?"
or, as we say, Marketing Mix
Models or Mix Media Models?
Good question, and I'm
going to preface this
by saying that I've worn
a lot of hats in 16 or 17
years of doing work like this
and definitely more on the--
I'm more interested
in the technical side
of implementing the solutions
that we're building.
But I can definitely
get anyone in touch
with some of our
colleagues who are
more familiar with the
statistical methodology
and the pros and cons there,
but I'll do my best to answer.
I think in some cases--
one thing I'll say is that
you need historical data,
or you need a great
way to simulate
what you think is a
good representation
of historical data
that doesn't exist.
And then that's the case with
a lot of-- with pretty much any
model you build, but in some
cases, for marketing data,
a lot of times, that data
doesn't exist or isn't in--
you might have data that's--
Well, one thing I'll
say is, as marketing
is more digital nowadays
and is being executed
through all sorts of
different social media
platforms or other
online platforms,
what you might be
able to extract out
of those platforms may not be
in the best form for a model.
It might not be in the most
ideal form that you'd want,
you know?
Let's say you have new
customer signups by day--
just some generic term, right?
But maybe you can only get
Facebook advertising spend
at a week level or something.
So there's assumptions
you can make
about spreading
some of that data
around to try and get it
to fit the structure you
need for building a model.
So I would say that, in terms of
pros and cons, it's dependent--
if you like data munging,
it's a great space
to be in because you
get data from all
these disparate systems, and
it's all in different formats,
and your job is to
blend it in a way that
makes logical sense for
explaining the problem
that you're working on.
The pros, I'll say--
and this is the
most obvious one--
is that you can have a
conversation with the CMO
and tell them that you've got a
sound statistical approach that
suggests channel
x has contributed
y percent towards this
particular outcome,
and a different channel
has contributed this.
And had you done
this instead, this
might have been the
outcome, and you
can test that going forward and
over the next quarter or six
months or whatever.
And a lot of times, that's
eye-opening for a CMO.
There's a lot of pressure, I
think, on CMOs, Chief Marketing
Officers, these days to show--
they spend a lot
of money, right?
So there's a lot
of pressure to show
the value of all that spend.
And if every channel that
you execute stuff through
is probably going to offer some
kind of reporting attribution
that only looks at what
they do and only considers
it being the only
thing that somebody
might have been exposed to.
And, obviously, that's not
really practical, right?
So if you've got a tool that can
consider all the things you're
doing, where the spend all
adds up to your total budget,
and the outcomes
all add up to what
was observed by the whole
organization, and you can say,
based on our model, we think
that Facebook did this,
or Google did this, or
direct mail did this.
And so now that CMO can have
a much better conversation
with the CFO and the rest of the
organization about how they can
optimize that
budget to keep costs
under control while trying
to maximize the outcome--
new signups, new customers,
revenue, that sort of thing.
That's great.
Thank you.
Dan, I'd love to hear a
little bit about your journey
into your role now.
And I know you previously were
a analytics consultant as well.
What has the transition
been like into director
of analytics role?
Sure, sure, sure.
No problem.
I'll probably go back a
little bit more in time.
So I was going to
be a math teacher.
That was the start
of my journey.
So I got a bachelor's degree
in secondary math education
from Ohio University and,
towards the end of that,
decided I wanted to just keep
learning more math and stats.
I wasn't sure if I wanted to get
into public school education,
or at least wanted to put
it off for a little bit.
So I had an opportunity to stay
at OU and go to grad school
and study applied
math and statistics.
And right around that
time is when jobs in--
they weren't calling
it data science yet,
but it was definitely more
statistician, or maybe
if you're lucky, analytics jobs.
This was, like, 2006-ish.
And so, yeah, I thought this
stuff was super interesting.
And it wasn't like
actual science,
not to say that that's
not interesting,
but just the idea that there's
this emerging field of--
it's not fleshed out yet.
You're kind of using a little
bit of computer science,
a little bit of math and
stats, and just some business,
or otherwise context acumen
to solve interesting problems.
And so when I finished school,
when I finished grad school,
I had a couple of different
jobs for a year or so,
each at larger companies.
And then had an
opportunity to work
for a locally owned consulting
company in Cleveland.
And that's really where
I spent a lot of time,
almost nine years
altogether, but went
from a consultant with a
few years of experience all
the way up through--
by the time I left
there, I was a director
and had been leading projects
and leading longer term
engagements, but also working
on R&amp;D side with new technology.
So that's what really got me
interested in this stuff was
they trusted me to work on
helping our company grow
into using this--
I'll go back,
like, 10 years ago.
There was just an explosion
of open source technology.
Like, there was a lot
of proprietary software
that was getting to
be very expensive,
and it became very well known
that tools like R or Python
were starting to become used
in more business contexts.
And, also, at the same time,
the argument used to be,
oh, well, it's in-memory
computing, and what can you do?
Like, computer has 2
gigs of RAM or whatever.
Well, then that price of
memory started going down,
and they started being able
to spin up virtual machines
and keep an eye on that
cost a little bit more.
So that's when we started,
and this is all just coming--
this is so interesting
of the timing of all this
because right around
the same time, it was,
like, RStudio was
getting bigger,
and there was more awareness
of the packages coming out.
Ggplot2 had already been pretty
big, I think, at the time,
but then those HTML
widgets came out.
And it's like, oh,
look what you can do.
You can embed an interactive
map or a table or something
in what looks to be a
presentation or a document
or something.
And this is totally the
section of this hour-long chat
where I could ramble.
So if you want to change gears,
Rachael, you can stop me, but--
DAN NEGREY: --I love
talking about this stuff.
This is great.
We have a lot of former
teachers on here, actually,
as well as wannabe math teachers
who are commenting in the chat
too.
[LAUGHS]
Well, I should mention that--
it's never left.
Like, I did never end up
teaching in a public school,
but I did teach undergrad
math in grad school.
And every job I've
had, I've taken it
as an unspoken responsibility
to train and teach people.
Especially as this stuff
has just exploded, there's--
I mean, if you're new, if
you're finishing school,
and if you've not had exposure
to a lot of this stuff,
you probably think,
where do I start?
These companies expect me to
be a brilliant statistician
and have 10 years of
computer science background
and all this kind of stuff,
and it's not practical.
So there needs to be good
training programs in place
at places and people patient and
excited about teaching others
how to use it.
But, yeah, so I
had an opportunity
to lead R&amp;D efforts at the one
consulting company I was at
and get us up to speed on Hadoop
and R and Python and Spark
and all this cool stuff.
And then, at some
point, I decided
it was time to move on
to a different role,
and I took a role at
a software company.
That's where Rachael
and I actually first met
because I was trying to get
RStudio Pro products installed
there.
And that was a great experience.
I learned a ton about B2B
software and the sales
and marketing process.
If you've only worked on--
like in a B2C environment,
working in a B2B environment
is much different in how
long everything takes and
the marketing efforts that
go into what could be a
year- or two-long sales
cycle with much bigger
price tag at the end,
so it's an interesting
experience.
But after a while, I wanted to
get back into just being more
hands-on,
data-science-developer-type,
but had accumulated a lot of
this experience that I could
reliably say that I'm--
call myself a leader
in this space,
even though I still
have imposter syndrome.
I'm looking at all of you,
and I'm immediately thinking,
I'm out of my league
here, and you guys
should be the ones talking.
So I met people at
MarketBridge, and I
knew that we clicked
in terms of our vision.
It was also a smaller company.
I think I just have a--
my preference is to just work
in a smaller company that
can move a little
bit faster and not
have as much red tape across
when it comes to trying things
out with technology.
So, yeah, so now we're here,
and I've kind of taken--
everything is cumulative.
Everything I've done
for the last 15 years,
I feel like I've tried
to put into play here.
And it's teaching others.
It's building
internal packages so
that we can abstract
problems and have
people use consistent functions
to address similar problems.
It's Shiny.
It's everything.
I mean, it's great.
It's exploring new ways of
data engineering that don't--
I still love a good
relational database,
but there's use cases
beyond that these days that
are requiring more just
cloud-based tools that are just
going in different
directions and trying
to keep a handle on all
these different things
and how they fit together.
I think that's another
good point, too, is like--
and, actually, if you've
ever been in a sales pitch
or in a meeting where
that's been sort of pitchy
with sales and
marketing, if you've ever
seen a slide that's just
got logos blasted on it,
I feel like that,
sometimes, when
you talk about data
science and technology,
you could get one of
those, and there could just
be every tool in the
world you think about.
So again, it's one of
those things of thinking
about what does what?
How does it fit together, right?
Like, it's amazing that you
can do a ton of stuff in R,
and I literally mean a ton.
But it can be even
cooler when you
think about how it can work
with other software or hardware,
for example.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Yeah.
DAN NEGREY: I'll
give a plug for pins.
Pins has been a huge
package that we've
started using a year or so ago.
And we've just got
into using Azure blob
containers as the boards
for pinning objects
and reading from.
So if you've never
used pins, it's
definitely worth
checking out, even
if you're using local folders
as the backend boards.
Just the idea of
abstraction there
is really cool in what
you can do with it.
I love the pins shout-out.
I put the link to
it in the chat.
I was trying to
grab an example too
that shows a whole data science
workflow with pins as well,
and I'll put it into
the chat when I find it.
But, Dan, I was going to say--
well, thank you for
sharing the journey,
but also, so many of us feel
imposter syndrome here as well,
but we're all here
getting over that.
But this is awesome.
Thank you so much.
There are a few anonymous
questions that came through,
and one was, "Are there
any specific packages
that you find are good for
manipulating and displaying
time series data or
packages for missing data?"
Sure.
So this is interesting
so because I
started learning R before
the tidyverse, if you ever
looked at my code, you're going
to see a nice blend of bracket
subsetting meets dplyr
meets all sorts of stuff.
But I believe it's
sound, and it could
be totally different than
somebody else's approach.
So sometimes--
this is probably--
this could be a fault of mine.
Sometimes I probably
code things up
the long way because
it's immediately
the solution that comes to mind
when there's probably already
a package that does
it in a simple call.
But that's the fun of it, right?
That's the fun is solving
problems and thinking about how
it should be solved
and then coding it
up yourself, even
if at first glance,
it's not the most efficient way.
So dplyr is just incredible.
I remember being at--
I'm trying to remember exactly
what it was, if it was a useR!
Conference.
I think it was a useR!
conference at UCLA
in 2014 or something,
and they did a talk about dplyr,
and I thought it was a game
changer because now,
all of a sudden,
what I found is people had hard
time figuring out manipulating
data in R with the apply()
functions and bracket
subsetting and that sort of
thing when they were used
to an approach that was
more like SQL or SaaS.
So dplyr comes along, and it
sort of speaks to them on how--
gives them a new toolset
for manipulating data.
So as far as time series stuff
goes, I know, for a while,
I was using xts and dygraphs to
get more of formal time series
objects and visualize those.
Dygraphs was
incredible with its--
I mean, I'm blown away
when I saw the sliders.
And if you're not
familiar with it,
you imagine a time series plot
that, right out of the box,
has sliders at the bottom
that you can easily
pinch in and pull apart and
see different parts of the time
and hover-overs and everything.
I started using Plotly
a ton for visualization
just because it can do so
much besides time series.
So I just find it--
got used to using
their framework
for handling a lot of different
visualization problems.
Thank you.
So going back to pins
for just a second
because I just was reading
Libby's comment in the chat--
if somebody was just getting
started with using pins now,
is there a specific
resource you'd recommend?
Yeah, I thought
pins.rstudio.com is--
I still pull that up in
my browser all the time
and even read through the first
page or the couple of articles
that are embedded there.
It does a great job
of explaining it,
especially, I
think, the examples
start with just
using a folder right
near your working directory
that can be used to pin stuff.
And then once you see
what it's doing there,
and then you look at what
all the other backend storage
options, it's--
sometimes you've got
to deal with like,
OK, well, you don't have to
authenticate to a folder that's
next to your working
directory, but you
do with an Azure blob storage.
So connecting to that
board is the hurdle.
But once you have the
board established,
then you're past that point,
and it can be really cool.
So start with the
basic examples.
Yeah.
Perfect.
I just put the link
here because I realized
the one I shared before
was only pins for R,
but there's also
pins for Python too.
Eric, I see you were putting
a plug for a package as well.
Do you want to jump in?
Hello.
Yeah, this has been
a wonderful talk,
and I really enjoyed learning
from your perspective.
Just on the topic of
additional packages,
first, yeah, I
love pins as well.
I've been using that in a lot
of my daily new workflows.
It's been making things
a lot more efficient.
But with interactive
visualizations,
I've been on a huge
journey of that as well.
I'll give a nice
verbal shout-out
as well for echarts4r
is another great way
to have some awesome visuals.
John is here in the audience.
It's helped a lot
of my major apps.
So if you're doing
interactive visuals
and need both the more standard
type of statistical displays
but also some really novel
displays, it's got you covered.
So I highly recommend
that as well.
Great, thanks, and
nice to meet you, Eric.
Appreciate that.
ERIC NANTZ: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
So one other
anonymous question
we had here was, "Do
you or your clients
use Power BI,
ClickView, or Tableau?"
Yeah, we have clients
that use all those things.
So our company has a lot
of Fortune 1000 clients,
and a lot of big companies
have enterprise BI tools.
And I've worked at
smaller companies, too,
that have used those as--
sort of led with those
as their Bi offerings.
It's interesting to think about
how Shiny or Connect plays
a role with those
things because it's
easy to-- and I've
played a role,
and it's easy to get into like,
oh, we don't need enterprise BI
tools.
We'll just do
everything in Shiny.
And a lot of times, I
have taken that stance,
and it doesn't go very well.
But I think those
tools have a good--
they serve a good
purpose in terms
of keeping an eye on a lot
of those KPIs and things
I measured before.
I think there's a good
audience for those tools,
and they're a great way to
learn data visualization
and manipulation.
I think where I've--
I guess one thing I'll say
about those is it's not
worth fighting about BI tools.
Like, you shouldn't probably
go into a conversation,
Shiny should replace this.
There's a lot of
things you'll find.
Even if the leadership
supports that, you'll find
there's a lot of
things that IT support
and human resources that
can do all the work,
and all that kind of
stuff comes into play.
So the conversation I
found as more helpful
is when you can demonstrate
what something like Shiny
can do that those tools can't
or the use case for those,
or serving up model scores
through plumber API and RStudio
Connect.
Like, that's a good
example of stuff
that's probably much
more difficult or maybe
even impossible to do in
some enterprise BI tools.
So try to focus on the
use cases that those tools
can help solve instead of coming
in with your sleeves rolled up.
That's a great point.
Thank you.
Oh, I will say, too,
there's some of the--
actually, just this
just came up recently
about integrating
Tableau with R.
And I had heard about the
Rserve integration a while ago,
and then explored it once
to see that it could work,
and then hadn't done
anything with it.
But we might have a use case
where we're doing something
with that.
So that's another--
it's fun to think
about the different roles you
can play in the type of work
we do, right?
And that's what I think is
cool about this type of work.
Like, sometimes, I could put my
hat on and just be a modeler,
and I don't care about
the prettiest visuals.
I'm trying to get a good model.
And sometimes, I could
be a data engineer,
and I'm trying to create
the most reproducible
or easy-to-follow pipeline
for moving data around.
And sometimes, I could
put my artistic hat on
and be trying to create
the most aesthetically
pleasing dashboard out there.
And I think it can
be kind of cool, too,
when you think that there's--
I think it goes back to what I
said about other technologies.
I would say if somebody else
has the role on the presentation
layer, we'll say, then
let them own that role,
and try to do what you can do
to get your stuff integrated
with that.
It could be a shared product
between the two of you.
Alan I see you had a question
on a project lifecycle.
Do you want to jump in?
Yeah, sure.
I'm curious again if there's
a kind of typical project
or if there's just
a ton of variation.
And going back to the root
of the question, I think,
is around like, do you end up
making robust infrastructure
for a customer that needs
an enduring way to collect
data that produces some
kind of output for them
that then they're monitoring?
And/or do they come in with a
bunch of data, and they say,
we need an analysis and a
way to answer this question
about market value?
Could both really point in terms
of different directions of how
you support what you make?
DAN NEGREY: Yeah.
And so I'm wondering if
there's one place you generally
land, or if every project
is kind of a consultative
endeavor, and, ultimately,
if it means-- like,
do you have a single
productized thing?
Or are you all over the map?
Yeah, a good question.
I would say the first part,
more the latter of clients
coming with their data so that
we can build models and reports
and analytics off of that.
In other cases, we're
in their environments
and having to do a lot
of the detective work
to figure out where data
is and how to get it.
And then in other
cases, finding out
that data still resides
in source systems,
and so we'll be in the
client environment--
I mean, this is
just another case.
So we might be the ones to
hook into that source system
and get it to our
environment, so we can
leverage our compute resources.
Or they might not
be cool with that,
and we have to stay
in their environment,
but we're still hooking
into the source system.
We've had situations where we've
built databases from the ground
up inside a client environment
so that we can ingest data
from some of those
systems to support
the different type of
analytics work we do.
So kind of all over
the map, really, with--
definitely have a preference
to what we'd want to do,
but in a lot of cases,
especially dealing with data,
there's compliance
and governance issues
and constraints
that maybe suggest
the type of environment
stuff can go or should go,
and we deal with a lot of that.
So a lot of variation and
a lot of customer-by-customer
problem solving.
Yeah, for the most part.
ALAN SCHUSSMAN: Cool, thank you.
Jared, I realize we
missed one of your questions
from a bit earlier.
Do you want to jump in here?
Oh, I don't know if
we can hear you yet.
Can you hear us?
JARED WOOLFOLK: Oh no.
Can you guys hear me OK?
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Oh, nope.
Yes, yes, we can.
JARED WOOLFOLK: Yeah, I guess my
question is more generalistic.
But handling client
ambiguity when
they come to you with a need,
if you have any tips, tricks
or insight or wisdom on shoring
up and getting more specifics
instead of more having
an aimless ship trying
to reach a destination
on reaching
a final result or a final
product that they are after
and how you've kind of handled
that through your career.
Sure, sure.
One thing I've seen
that's been helpful
is when engaging with a new
organization, new client,
is whether you show them this
or not is having a maturity
framework just so you
can assess where they're
at in terms of
data accessibility,
the types of analytics
or models or insights
they currently develop,
and the tools they use,
so get an understanding
of their environment.
If you plot all that out,
the first thing you might say
is that they're pretty low on--
they don't have hardly
any of this stuff.
So maybe the first thing--
And I hear what you're
saying about ambiguity.
They might have
that type of setup,
but then they might
also come to you
with very specific questions.
And you think, well, before
we can even get to this,
we have to set up
this foundation.
And if you can talk
to them about that,
maybe building that foundation
is a place you can start.
If they're not patient
enough for that,
you can get into
maybe more specifics
around the data that's needed
to answer the specific questions
they have.
I think a lot of times,
especially when you're
dealing with
leadership, they don't
know that that gap exists
between what they're
looking for and the
resources and tools they
have in place to achieve that.
So if you can
bring a perspective
on what you can do to
help them achieve that,
that's always huge.
And then just as far as other
ambiguity with questions,
I think that's come
with experience to--
this is where the context
and the business acumen
comes into play, right?
I say "business."
I like the word "context."
I don't like the word
"business acumen,"
but context of the
problem because you
could be working
for pharmaceuticals,
or you can be working
for local government.
The more you know
about the context,
the more you are aware of
the pitfalls that people
in decision-making roles--
that they'll run
into, and the more
you can anticipate situations
that they might encounter,
and you could do some
work to help support that.
Anyone that has maybe no coding
abilities but tons of contacts,
they're a valuable person to
have around because they can
help shape those conversations.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Absolutely.
JARED WOOLFOLK: That
makes a lot of sense.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Thanks, Dan.
DAN NEGREY: Mhm.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Yeah.
Thanks for all
these questions too.
I remember seeing
on LinkedIn-- and I
think it was maybe from Tatsu's
post about your Hangout.
But I heard that you have
several open positions
on your team for people
using R and Python,
so just wanted to make sure I
gave a minute here for those
too.
Yeah, we do.
Thanks for mentioning that.
So we're growing.
We're growing pretty
well, so always
looking for bright,
motivated people that
love to tackle
problems like these
or just love to solve
problems in general.
I think that's-- finding people
who are curious about how
things work and how to
solve problems is huge.
I'm trying my best to
copy the link here, But.
You might need to give
me a different one after,
but I think I got the right one.
OK, cool.
And I know a lot of--
some people reached out to
me on LinkedIn prior to this.
I will try to get
back to everybody.
I will say that I've had
an interesting experience
with having my own website.
So I did buy a domain
a couple of years ago,
and I let it lapse, and
then somebody took it.
It was dnegrey.com, and so
somebody took it last fall
when I didn't re-up the payment.
And it doesn't look anything
like the blog I had before.
And I'm also trying
to rewrite my website
or blog in Quarto, which
is going pretty well.
I'm just not ready to
push it out just yet.
So if you see old posts
of mine on LinkedIn,
and it says go to
dnegrey.com, it's
not going to look
like what you think.
And more likely
than not, I'm going
to just publish to my self
GitHub page's repo and point
people there, but--
Thanks for the heads up.
[LAUGHTER]
And there was just a
quick follow-up question
on the roles.
Are they mostly remote,
or are they in--
I see some say Washington, DC.
Yeah, our company is
based in Bethesda, Maryland,
but as I mentioned
before, I'm in Cleveland,
so I work entirely remote.
We've got people distributed.
Well, we've got a lot of
people there close to Bethesda.
They go into the office.
So we do have a
central office, but we
do have people spread
out across the country.
So it's kind of
a hybrid approach
depending on the person and the
role and what works for them
and what works for the
company and all that.
Great.
Thank you.
I see Libby had
asked in the chat,
"Do you have any book
recommendations for us?"
And, Libby, I'm going to put
a plug for that awesome notion
list that you have
of all the book
recommendations for
the Hangout if you
want to reshare that
in the chat too.
OK.
I assume the data science
books, but my favorite book
is The Hitchhiker's
Guide to the Galaxy,
so if you never read that,
you should give that a read.
But the ones I keep here all the
time that I'm always looking at
is Advanced R and R
Packages from Hadley.
Those are phenomenal resources.
it's.
In a box over here.
But there was R
Graphics Cookbook
I think I used a lot earlier
on All these books are--
it's great that they're
all available online now.
So I don't have as many physical
books like this laying around.
But the other one
that I swear by
and I tell people because I'm
a huge I'm a huge Linux guy--
so the moment I started
working in R and Python,
I thought, well, when
someone's like, oh,
there's open source,
free operating systems,
and they play nicer
with these tools.
I was floored, and I
got really into that.
There's a book called The Linux
Command Line by William Shotts,
and it's available
free as a PDF.
It's not too expensive
on Amazon either.
If you're interested in learning
more about Linux servers
and command-line tools,
it's a great introduction,
especially if you're not
familiar with that stuff
already--
kind of eases you, kind
of relates everything back
to some of the more GUI OS
stuff that you might already
be familiar with.
Thank you.
I see there's a
conversation happening
in the chat around,
I think, Sneehall,
you had a question on
any book recommendations
for Power BI or Power
BI with R. Does anybody
who put some recommendations in
there want to jump in as well?
Or, Josiah, I see
you're commenting
on using REST APIs there.
I don't want to put
anybody on the spot.
I just see it was an engaged
conversation happening.
I can comment on it.
I don't want to steal
anyone's thunder.
Sure, go ahead.
Not stealing anyone's thunder.
Feel free to raise
your hand, too,
if anybody wants
to add anything.
I'm a big advocate
of REST APIs.
Any software can
access a REST API.
So Power BI can
Tableau can access a REST
API, and anything can.
So the idea is
that you can make--
if you can run a function in
R, you can make a REST API.
So the question
just then becomes,
how do you host that REST API?
So maybe you want to
have a function that
manipulates your data.
If you want Power BI to use
that, all you need to do
is make it accessible
via API and then Power--
I just found like 10 media
posts on this just by one Google
search, how to connect
Power BI to REST API.
That's simple.
The question is, how do
you host this REST API?
And then making those two
things talk to each other
is probably quite trivial.
The hosting part's
the hard part,
but I'm sure there's 25
people in this chat who
can help you figure out how
to do that with Connect.
[LAUGHS] But I think
all I want to say
is that you can
write a function.
You can make a REST API.
Awesome.
Thanks for that.
Thank you for all
the recommendations
there and on other
books too in the chat
I see Tatsu just put a shout-out
for DevOps for Data Science
by Alex Gold.
We should definitely
add that one to the list
too and capture
some of those there.
So, Dan, I know we're coming
up quickly on our time here,
but a question I
wanted to ask you--
and I think we touched
on it a little bit--
is when you think
of the year ahead
for your team, what is something
that you're most excited about?
Oh, good question.
I think about the work
we're doing with my team
specifically, with
the work we're
doing with marketing
effectiveness,
and I think what excites
me the most about that
is that we've done a
lot of these projects
and are approaching it
from, how do we abstract it?
Like, there's so
many things in common
from one project to the next.
And so we're not--
yes, every client
can be different.
Every outcome could be
different whether, it's
a count of something or a
spend amount or whatever.
So we're always thinking about
how these problems relate
and how they're common
from one to the other
or how they differ
so that we can
expand how we abstract those.
And when you can
abstract a problem,
you can create reusable
solutions and classes
and methods, and that's exactly
what we're trying to do.
So that helps us be more
consistent with the way
we approach the problems.
And it's sort of a
self-sustaining model
too because then
we can train people
on how these things
work, and we can
reason about them the same way
when we talk to each other.
It's a very exciting way to
approach this type of work
that I've wanted
to do for a while
but just finally have the
opportunity to approach it
this way with our support
of our leadership.
So it's really cool.
That's great.
Thank you, Dan.
I just wanted to
check that I haven't
missed people's questions
or anything from the chat.
So feel free to just raise
your hand here on Zoom.
I love the conversation
that happens in the chat.
That is so cool.
And sometimes, I think we might
miss a few questions in there,
so just want to double-check.
One other thing
I'll say while we're
waiting on that is what I'd
love to see in the next year
is more Quarto
Revealjs presentations.
It's very cool, very innovative.
Something similar was available
with ioslides a while ago,
but, obviously, this
approach with Quarto
is a little bit superior.
So that becomes-- like, if
you think about business
and business presentations, like
having to copy and paste stuff
into PowerPoint,
even though I know
Quarto can output
PowerPoint now too,
but I would love to see
those types of presentations
have a greater presence in
terms of data science delivery.
I was actually just
talking with somebody
on our open source team
yesterday about this Quarto
Revealjs because he was
thinking of a conference talk
that he wanted to submit.
And so I would love
to hear from you,
what would you like
to see for that?
Would you like to see
templates, or what?
The first thing I--
yeah, templates,
and I know there's--
people are constantly adding
to the assets available there,
but I just remember the first
thing when that got announced,
I immediately checked
if it could support
HTML widgets because that
was the reason I went
to ioslides a while ago instead
of RStudio Presentation that
was built in, because when I've
showed people that, oh, here's
a table with 400 rows,
but you can see 10, 25,
or 100, or however many you want
at a time and page through it,
versus just a Microsoft Office
table embedded into a thing.
That really blew their mind.
So I'd ask just
continuous support
for the different
visualizations, especially
the more JavaScript
interactive ones that can
introduce some interactivity.
Great.
Thank you so much.
I'll share that feedback with
them too and maybe, if it's OK,
introduce you to
them at some point.
Sure.
Yeah, no problem.
OK, one last question for
you, which I always think is fun
to ask-- is there a piece
of career advice that
you've received or given
that comes to mind?
It doesn't have to be the best
or favorite, but something
that was impactful.
Yeah, I think it comes back to
imposter syndrome and all that.
So have a lot of confidence
in your background,
in your academic background,
in your work experience,
even in your thought process
for approaching problems.
Somebody that was my
boss a long time ago--
when I said something that
illustrated that I wasn't
sure of myself or
whatever, and he just said,
you have a master's
degree in math.
And not that everyone has to
have a master's degree in math,
but it's just like,
you know what?
Like, you can do this, right?
You have all the tools you need.
You can communicate to people.
You can reason about problems.
You can do this.
I love that.
Thank you so much, Dan,
for joining us here
and sharing your
experience with us all.
If people want to get in touch,
is LinkedIn the best way?
It sounds like not the blog yet.
Yeah.
LinkedIn.
I'm on Twitter.
If you search for my name,
you'll probably find me,
but somewhere around there
is an email address too.
Whatever you want, I'm
usually pretty open.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Perfect.
I got three kids, though,
so I might take a while
to get back to people.
[LAUGHS] Sounds good.
Well, thank you so much, Dan.
Have a great rest of
the day, everybody.